in this video you're going to work with
complex and imaginary numbers and we're
going to talk about what exactly are
imaginary numbers and how to add them
and subtract them and multiply them and
divide them so let's get started with
this video
the first thing you want to know is
this right here the square root of
negative 1 we call that I for Imaginary
now we know
when you take the square root like if I
say what's the square root of 16 we say
what number times itself is 16 that's 4
right but if we say what's the square
root of negative 16
what would that be well we can't say 4
times 4 that's positive 16 or negative 4
times negative 4 that's positive 16. so
how do we take the square root of a
negative number that's where imaginary
numbers come in now another thing you
want to know about this notation here I
is that if we Square both sides of this
equation I squared is equal to negative
1 because when I Square the left side
and the right side the square and the
square root cancel and you're just
getting negative 1. so these are good to
remember right here but when I simplify
a square root that's got a negative in
it what I like to do is split it up into
two parts square root of negative 1
times square root of 16. the square root
of negative 1 is I the square root of 16
is 4 so all together I would write this
as 4i
okay now a complex number what's a
complex number well it's part real and
it's part imaginary and it's oftentimes
written in this a plus bi form the a
represents the real part and the bi
represents the imaginary part and this
is called the standard form of a complex
number so all these years when your
teacher was saying three
it was implied that it was three plus
zero I that there was no imaginary part
or if you say let's say 2i like this is
imaginary number it's really 0 plus 2i
but we don't oftentimes write the zero
but this is what a complex number is
part real part imaginary so let's get
into some of these examples this first
one say we want to simplify the square
root of negative 48. well what we can do
is we can
break this down we could say negative 1
times
the square root of 48 so square root of
negative 1 times square root of 48
that's the square root of negative 1. we
already talked about that's I 48 we can
simplify into square root of 16 times
square root of 3 that's 48 and square
root of 16 is a perfect square that's
four
so if we rewrite this now we can write
it as 4 I square root of 3
and that's our final result now
sometimes students will mistakenly put
the eye over here which you could do the
only thing is that it's oftentimes not
written that way because it looks like
the eye might be underneath the radical
so to kind of avoid that confusion we
usually put it up in front here let's
look at number two now so this one we
have square root of negative 3 times
square root of negative 15. now a
mistake that students sometimes make is
they just multiply these together and
say oh that's the square root of 45 and
simplify from there you don't want to do
that what you want to do is you want to
split this up into
square root of negative 1 times square
root of 3 and square root of negative 15
is square root of negative 1 times
square root of 15. square root of
negative 1 we know is I
and this square root of negative 1 is I
or
and so I times I we know is I squared
square root of 3 times square root of 15
is square root of 45 and now we know I
squared is equal to negative 1
and the square root of 45 is 9 times 5 9
is a perfect square that's 3 times
negative 1 this will give us negative 3
square root of 5. if we just multiply
these together and say square root of 45
you're going to get positive 3 root 5.
so you want to make sure you take that
square root of negative 1 out first
okay for number three now how do we
simplify this one well we can see we've
got that I squared in here I squared is
negative 1 times 3 is going to give us a
negative three
minus 5i now we can't combine these
because you've got an imaginary and a
real number and they're two different
types of terms you can kind of think of
i as like a variable like X or Y or Z so
you really can't combine a number with a
variable if you're just adding or
subtracting they're unlike terms you
also want to make sure you put this real
part first in the imaginary part second
in this a plus bi standard form
okay for number four now we're adding
two complex numbers together so again
just like we said I can be sort of
thought of like a as like a variable
like X or Y and you can think about just
combining like terms so we could say 2
plus 3 is equal to 5.
1i plus negative 5i is negative 4i and
that's in our standard form of a complex
number real plus imaginary or a plus bi
form
number five we've got the same two
complex numbers but we're subtracting
this time
what you can do is you can think of this
as like a negative one and distribute
that negative 1 into the parentheses so
this is like negative 3 plus 5i and now
all we have to do is combine like terms
2 plus negative 3 is negative 1. 1i plus
5i is 6i and we have it in the standard
form of a complex number real plus
imaginary let's take a look at a few
more examples
okay for number six now we're
multiplying two complex numbers together
you can see they're side by side with
nothing in between so multiplication and
here again you can think of that I as
like a variable like X or Y and so we
have like a binomial times a binomial we
can do the foil method or the box method
or the distributive property twice here
I'll just distribute twice I'll do 2
times 3 which is 6.
2 times negative 5i is negative 10i then
I'm going to distribute the I so I times
3 is 3i and I times negative 5i is
negative 5i squared now we know over
here I squared is equal to negative one
so we have a negative 1 I squared to
negative 1 times negative 5 is positive
5.
here we have negative 10i plus 3i is
negative 7i bring down the 6 and again
combining like terms 6 plus 5 is 11
minus 7i and we have it in that standard
form with the real number First and the
imaginary number second
okay for number seven now we're dividing
and when you're dividing you don't want
to have I in the denominator that's
considered improper just like you don't
want to have a radical or a square root
in the denominator so what we do when
it's a binomial like two terms like this
we multiply by the complex conjugate
what's the complex conjugate if you have
a plus bi you multiply by a minus bi or
if you have a minus bi you multiply by a
plus bi so you just change that sign in
between
so here we're going to multiply by 2
minus I whatever you do to the
denominator you want to do to the
numerator because that's like
multiplying by one
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to
multiply these together so 5 times 2 is
10.
5 times negative I is negative 5i
in the denominator what's interesting is
the inside and the outside cancel we
have 2i and negative 2i that's zero so
we just get 2 times 2 which is 4 I times
negative I is negative I squared
I squared is negative 1 times this
negative is a positive one so that
becomes four plus one which is five so
we have 10 minus 5i over five and you
don't want to leave it like that you
want to split this up into two parts the
real part and the imaginary part 10
divided by 5 is 2.
and negative 5 divided by 5 is negative
1 I okay so you've got it in the
standard form real plus imaginary now
here I did a little bit of a shortcut
where I did the inside and outside
cancel and then I just did the first
multiply together and the last if you
don't like that method just distribute
twice distribute the 2 then distribute
the I and you'll see the cancellation
that occurs
okay for number eight now we have a
monomial or just one term in the
denominator but we still have that I in
the bottom which is considered improper
so how do we get rid of this I well here
we can just multiply the numerator and
denominator by I I or I is equal to one
one times anything is not going to
change the value it's just going to
change the way that it looks so 8 times
I is 8i
negative 3i times I is negative 3 I
squared I squared we know is negative
one a negative 3 times a negative 1 is a
positive three
so we get eight thirds I
okay good and then for number nine and
number ten this is what I call I to a
higher power like you know instead of
just I to the first or I to the second
it's like either to a higher exponent
and you can see I to the 27th the way I
like to do these problems is I like to
divide out groups of two so what I mean
by that is you could write this as I
squared
to the 13th power
sequence power to power you multiply 2
times 13 is 26. we need one more I so
let's multiply it by I to the first
now the reason I do that is because I
squared is negative 1 right and negative
1 is easy to work with a negative 1
times a negative 1 times a negative 1
like 13 times a negative to an odd power
is going to be negative and then times
this I is just going to be
negative I so it's an easy way to
simplify some teachers explain it where
it repeats like here I'll show you I to
the first they say is I and then I
squared is negative 1 and I to the third
is negative I and then I to the fourth
is equal to 1 and then it repeats I to
the fifth sixth seventh eighth nine ten
eleven twelve
I find this to be a little bit easier a
little bit less to memorize so for I to
the 60th let's do the same thing here
let's see 2 goes into 60 30 times see
Power to power we multiply we know I
squared is negative 1 but a negative
number to an even power is going to be
positive so this just comes out to
positive one and you simplified it so
great job if you're able to follow these
examples if you want more practice and
you want to test yourself follow me over
to another video I did on the same topic
adding subtracting multiplying and
dividing complex and imaginary numbers
check out that video and I'll see you
over there